I was in Washington for most of the week
prospecting for gold
another byproduct of that was that I
forgot to arrange a substitute for Bob
Berwick for the Thursday recitations I
shall probably go to hell for this
in any event we have many explanations
none of them good but today we'll try to
get back on track and you'll learn
something fun in particular you'll learn
how a graduate student of mine mark
Fillion together with a summer urops
student bread fans Uddin what have you
managed to pull off a tour de force and
recognize in these two descriptions the
pattern that we humans commonly call
revenge it was discovered the system
didn't have a name for it of course they
just knew there was a pattern there and
sat waiting for us to give a name to it
that's where we're that's where we're
going to end up but it'll be a bit of a
journey before we get there because we
got to go through all that stuff on the
outline and in particular we want to
start off by a little tiny bit of review
because some of the stuff we did last
time went by pretty fast and
particularly you may remember they had
this wonderful joint probability table
which tells us all we want to know all
we want to know we can decide what the
probability of the police being called
is given the this and the that and all
that sort of stuff by clicking the
appropriate boxes the trouble is gee
there are only three variables are there
and when there are lots of variables it
gets pretty hard to make up those
numbers or to even collect them so we're
driven to an alternative and we got to
that alternative just at the end of the
show a week ago and we got to the point
where we were defining these inference
Nets sometimes called Bayes Nets and the
one we worked with look like this
there's a burglar a raccoon the
possibility of a dog barking the police
being called a trash can being
overturned some more variables than that
those that'll has three this has got
five but we're able to do some magic
with this because we us humans when we
define when we draw this graph we're
making an assertion about how things
depend or don't depend on one another in
particular there's something to write
down and and and and memorize the point
where rolls off your tongue and that is
that any variable in this graph is said
by me to be independent of any other non
descendant given its parents independent
of any non descendant given its parents
so that means that the probability of
the dog barking given its parents
doesn't depend on T the trashcan being
overturned because the intuition is all
of the causality is flowing through the
parents and can't get to this variable D
without going through the parents so
that is an asserted property of the nets
that we draw and we tend to draw them in
a way that reflects causality so it
tends to make sense so somehow this
thing this thing is going to be we're
going to use this thing instead of that
thing but wait we may need that thing in
order to do all the computations we want
to perform so we need to be able to show
that we can get to that thing by doing
calculations on this thing so what to do
well we're going to use the chain rule
remember that the chain rule came to us
by way of the basic axioms of
probability plus the definition plus a
little colored chalk so we got to the
point last time where we sort of believe
this it's a really magical thing it says
that the probability of all this stuff
happening together is given as the
product of a bunch of
conditional probabilities and the
conditional probabilities in this
product are arranged such that this
first guy depends on everybody else the
second guy doesn't depend on the first
guy but depends on everything else so
that list of dependencies get smaller
and smaller as you go down here until it
depends only on one thing there's no
there's no conditional at all so that's
going to come to our rescue in and
because it enables us to go from
calculations in here to that whole table
but first I have to show you a little
bit a little bit more slowly how that
comes to be what I'm going to do before
I think about probability is I'm going
to make a linear list of all these
variables and the way I'm going to make
it is I'm going to chew away from those
variables from the bottom and take an
advantage of a very important property
of these nets and that is there are no
loops you can't follow the arrows in any
way says that you get back to yourself
so there's always going to be a bottom
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
say well there are two bottoms here
they're C and T so I have a choice I'm
going to choose C somewhere pretend that
I'm going to I'm going to take that off
and pretend that it's not there anymore
then I'm going to take this guy that's
now now a bottom because there's nothing
below it I've already taken C out so
we'll take that out next and now I've
got this guy this guy in this guy this
guy no longer has anything below it so I
can list it next now over here I've got
raccoon and trashcan but trashcan
trashcan is at the bottom so I've got to
take it next because I'm working from
the bottom up I want to ensure that
there are no descendants before me in
this list so finally I get to raccoon so
the way I've constructed this list like
so ensures that this list arranges the
elements so that for any particular
element
none of its descendants appear to its
left alright and now that's the magical
order that I want to use for which I
want to use the chain rule so now I can
write I can pick C to be my variable end
and I can say that the chain rule says
that the joint probability of all these
variables P M C D V T and R the
probability of any particular
combination of those things is equal to
the probability of C given everybody
else next in line is D given everybody
else next in line is T next in line is B
given everybody else and next in line is
T given everybody else and finally just
R so this combination of things has a
probability that's given by this chain
rule expression ah but first of all none
of those expressions condition any of
the variables on anything other than
non-descendants all right that's just
because of the way I've arranged the
variables and I can always do that
because there are no loops
I can always two away at the bottom that
ensures that whenever I write a variable
it's going to be conditioned on stuff
other than its descendants so all of
these variables in any of these problems
conditional probabilities are non
descendants the weight when I drew this
diagram I asserted that no variable
depends on any non descendant given its
parents so if I know the parents of a
variable I know that the variable is
independent of all other non descendants
all right now I can start scratching
about well let's see I know that see
from my diagram has only one parent D so
given its parent it's independent of all
other non descendants so I can scratch
them out D has two parents B and are we
given that I can scratch out any other
non dependent non descendant B is
conditional on T and R I would be has no
parents so it actually is independent of
those two guys the trash can yeah that's
dependent on R & R over here the final
thing in the chain that's just the
probability so now I have a way of
calculating any entry in that table
because any entry in that table is going
to be some combination of values for all
those variables well on so anything I
can do with the table I can do in
principle with this little network okay
but now the question is I've got a some
probabilities I'm going to have to
figure out here so lets me let me draw a
slightly a different version of it so up
here we got the UH priori probability of
B well that's the probability of B
down here with the dog I've got a bigger
table because I got a probabilities that
depend on the values of his parents the
probability of dog barking depends on
the probability depends on the condition
of the parents nothing else so let's see
I've got to have a column for B I've got
to have a column for the raccoon the
burglar in a raccoon and there are a
bunch of possibilities for those guys
once I get those then I'll be able to
calculate the probability of dog barking
so there are two of these variables so
there are four combinations there's titi
there's TR RT and well what am i doing
wake up T false false true and false
false so what I really want to do is I
want to calculate all of these
probabilities to give the probability of
the dog conditioned on the condition of
the of the burglar and the raccoon
similarly I want to calculate the
probability of B happening doesn't
depend on anything else so I don't know
what to do well I would I'm going to
actually do is I'm going to do the same
thing I had to do up there I'm going to
keep track of I'm going to try a bunch
of I'm going to get myself together a
bunch of data maybe I do a bunch of
experiments maybe somebody hands it to
me but I'm going to use that data to
construct a bunch of tallies which is
gone at which are going to end up giving
me the probabilities for all of those
things so I don't know let's see how
should we start find step one fine
colored chalk
step two I'm going to extend these
tables a little bit so I can keep track
of the tallies
so this is going to be all the ones that
end up in a particular row and these are
going to be the ones for which dog is
true simply I'm going to extend this guy
up here in order to keep track of some
tallies this is going to be the ones for
which B is true and this one will be all
so that's my that's my setup and now
suppose that my first experiment comes
roaring in and it's all teas
so I have tea tea tea that's my first
experimental result my first data item
so let's see the arrangement here is
burglar raccoon dog so burglar has a
true and there's one tally count in
there likewise the TT that's the burglar
in raccoon that brings me down to this
first row so that gives me one tally in
there and dog is true so that gives me a
tick mark on that one all right
you with me so far analysis pose it next
thing happens to be all false
well burglar is false but there is one
experiment
everybody is false so we come down here
to false false and that's the row we're
going to work on we get a tally in there
so you put one in here no because that's
false dog is false that's all right
that's as much data element says so
that's cool maybe one more let's suppose
we have
TTFN well in that case we have a tick
mark here and tick mark here because the
burger element is true then we have TT
that brings us to the first row again so
we get a tick mark there but dog is fall
so no take mark there that's how it
works I suppose you'd like to see a
demonstration right boys like to see a
demonstration so here's what here's what
it actually looks like so on the left
you see the network as we've constructed
it with a bunch of probabilities there
and what I want to do now is I'm going
to start simulating away so as to
accumulate tick marks tally marks and
see what kinds of probabilities that
they indicate for the table I happen to
be using a process for which the model
on the left is a is a correct reflection
so there's one simulation also the dog
barking let's see the burglar is false
the raccoon is true I get one tick mark
so the probability there is one of
course I'm not going to just leave go
with one I want to put a whole bunch of
stuff in there so I'll just run a bunch
more simulations note that I don't even
have an entry at all yet forty F here
that's because I haven't run enough data
so let's let me clear it instead of
doing it one of the time let me run 100
simulations see it's still not too good
because it says there's t t
probabilities is true this is because
I'm feeding your data right and I'm
keeping track of what the data elements
tell me about how frequently a
particular combination appears yes Tanya
yeah what I'm doing one simulation just
keeping track of that combination in
each of these tables because it's going
to tell me something about the
probabilities that I want reflected in
those tables so it's pretty easy to see
when I go up here to burglar you know if
I have a lot of data elements they're
all going to tell me something about the
burglar as well as the other variables
so if I just look at that burglar thing
the fraction of time that it turns out
true over all the data elements is going
to be its probability so now when I get
out of the joint tables I can still get
these probability numbers but now
they're condition on particular
condition of its parents so that's how
that's how I get these probabilities so
I didn't do too well here we
that TT combination gave me an
excessively high probability so maybe a
hundred simulations isn't enough
let's run ten thousand so with that much
data running through the probabilities I
get let's see I've got eight nine three
here instead of 0.9 807 instead of 0.8
607 instead of 0.6 and that one's
dead-on at 0.01 so if I run enough of
these simulations I get a pretty good
idea what the probabilities ought to be
given that I've got a correct model okay
so that takes care that one and of
course I didn't draw the other things in
here but by extension you can see how
those would work
oh but you know what I think I will put
a little probability of Raccoon table in
here because the next thing I want to do
is I want to go the other way this is
recording tallies from some process so I
could develop a model but once I've got
these probabilities of course then I can
start to simulate what the model would
do all right how would I do that
well do I do now what do I want to use
the same table I think just to keep
things sanitary what I'll do is I'll go
over here and do it again
here's B it's got a probability of B
here's our here's a table probability of
R that comes down into a joint table or
dog and it's got four elements
depending on the burglar condition and
the raccoon condition we get a
probability of dog and now imagine these
have all been filled in so what do I
want to do if I want to simulate this
system generating some combination of
values for all the variables well I do
with the opposite of what I did when I
was working around with this chain rule
showing that I could go from the table
to those probabilities now I've got two
probabilities I'm going to go the other
direction instead of trying away from
the bottom I'm going to chew away from
the top because when I go into the top
and chew away everything I need to know
to do a coin flip is there so in
particular when I go up here up in here
I've got the probability of burglar now
so I'm going to use that probability to
flip a coin and say it produces a team
so that takes care of this guy and I can
now scratch it off since it's no longer
in consideration it's no longer a top
variable so now I go over to raccoon I
do the same thing I take this
probability I do a flip and say it
produces an F whatever its probability
is I flip a biased coin and that's what
I happen to get but now having dealt
with these two guys that uncovers this
dog thing and now I got enough
information because I've done everything
above to make a calculation for whether
the dog is going to be barking or not
but wait I have to know that I've got it
T at T and a T and F and F and a T and
an F and an F because I have to select
the right row so I know that B is T I
know that R is f so that takes me into
the table and then the second row so now
I get this probability I flip I flipped
that coin and I get some result say T
well I could do that with all the other
two variables and I've got myself an
experimental trial that is
used in accordance with the
probabilities in the table okay of
course of course yeah in fact how did I
get those numbers actually what I did is
I use the model on the left to generate
the samples that were used to compute
the probabilities and the right so
you've seen that you've seen a
demonstration of this already
now of course I don't know
all this sort of depends on having
everything right I've written a thing to
write it one more time
burglar raccoon dog call the police
trashcan but somebody else might sale
you got it all wrong this is the way it
really looks like the dog doesn't care
about Dracula tall so that's a correct
model now when I do a simulation I could
fill in the tables in either model right
I'm sure you'd like to see a
demonstration so let me show you a
demonstration of that so there are the
two tables and I can run 10,000
simulations on those guys too and look
the guy on the left is pretty good
reflection of the probabilities in the
model I use to stimulate two to produce
the data but the guy on the right
doesn't know any better it just fills in
its own tables too so what to do I say
this one's the right model and you say
that one's the right model who's right
well maybe we'll never know and the guy
on the left will get richer the stock
market the guy on the right will go
broke
it'll be nice if we can figure out who's
right so would you like to see how to
figure out who's right yeah so what
we're going to do is we're going to look
at naive Bayesian inference and that's
our next chore so here here's how it
works we know from the definition of
conditional probability we know that the
probability of a given B is equal to the
probability of a and B divided by the
probability of B right equal to by
definition so that means that the
probability of a given B times the
probability of B I'm just multiplying it
out is a
that joint probability oh but by
symmetry there's no harm and saying I
can do it I can turn that around and say
that the probability of B given a time's
the probability of B is also equal to
that joint from that joint probability
right I just expanded a different and
symmetric way if I got to write a B on B
ba on a thank you who is complaining
good work that would have been a
major-league disaster but now having
written out I can forget about the
middle is all really interested in is
how I've turned the probabilities around
in that conditional why would I care
about doing after that by the way we're
now talking about the work of the
Reverend days because we can rewrite
this yet again as the probability of a
given B is equal to the probability of B
given a time's the probability of a
divided by the probability of B that's
just Elementary algebra but now I'm
going to do something magical I'm going
to say I've got a classification problem
I want to know which disease you have
that's a classification problem maybe
you've got two swine flu maybe you've
got indigestion who knows but I get all
these symptoms I get all these pieces of
evidence you've got a fever
you're throwing well let's not go into
too much detail there but what I'm going
to do is I'm going to say well let's
suppose that a is equal to a class that
I'm interested in the disease you've got
and B is equal to the evidence
the symptoms I observe voila and they
have a pretty hard time figuring out
what the probability of the class is
given the evidence but figuring out the
probability evidence given the class
might not be so hard let me get another
board in play and show you what I mean
by plugging class and evidence into
Bayes rule what I get is the probability
of some class given the evidence is
equal to the probability of the evidence
given the class times the probability of
the class divided by probability of the
evidence now you're going to let that
sink to you a little bit suppose I got
several classes that I'm trying to
decide between I'm trying to select the
best out of it that batch of classes
well I've got the evidence and if I know
the probability of the evidence given
each of those classes and if I know the
operatory the initial probability of the
class and I'm done because I got the two
elements in the numerator
why am I done because the denominator is
the same for all the classes it's just
the probability of the evidence and then
I could just sum everything up I know it
has to one anyway so that's cool but
sometimes this evidence actually there's
not more than one piece of evidence
let's say that there's some class some
eye and we're trying to figure out if
that's the correct class so we got C sub
I there and C so by there and suppose
that that evidence is actually a bunch
of pieces of evidence so it could be e 1
e n hoops
a premature right bracket all that
evidence given the class I times the
probability of the class I over some
denominator that we don't care about
because it's going to be the same for
everybody so just write that as D now
what if these pieces of evidence are all
independent given a class so if you have
the swine flu the probability you have a
fever is independent of the probability
you're going to throw up say then can we
write this another way an easier way
sure because when things are independent
the joint probability is equal to the
product is equal to product of the
individual probabilities so that is to
say it's easier to see if you write it
down and if you just say it this
probability here from these two elements
here is equal to the probability of e 1
conditioned on C sub I times the
probability of e 2 conditioned on C sub
I all the way down to the probability of
en addition I see some high / some
denominator we don't care about see what
I'm trying to do is I'm going to go over
I'm going to go through this for all the
C I and see which one's the biggest this
is the probability of
right here oh yeah thanks hmm can't
write think at the same time Thanks
okay so I've just figure out which one
of these is biggest and I've identified
the class now you say to me well I would
like to see an example so I don't know
does anyone have any spare change
nickel a quarter this is not because of
our infant estimate lilo raises here at
MIT I just need it for demonstration and
we need two coins don't forget to get
these back I've tend to be now suppose
these two coins are not exactly the same
one of these points is a legitimate
highly prized American quarter the other
one is a fake and with this one the
probability of heads let us say is 0.8
instead of 0.5 so I mix these all up and
I pick one and I start flipping it and I
get a head and then I flip it again and
I get a tail which point did I pick well
we're going to use this stuff to figure
it out here's what happens
before I forget thank you very much so
what we've done is we've selected these
things from my hands and I can't draw
hands so I'll draw a little cup here and
there two coins in here and we're going
to pick one and one has a probability of
heads of equal to 0.8 and this one has a
probability of 1/2 of 0.5 so here's the
draw I pick one each has a probability
of 0.5 this one is the one with the 0.8
is the probability of head and this one
is 1 with the probability 0.5 is a head
ok so now suppose the first flip as it
was is team well that's piece of
evidence that's here probably the
evidence given the class well in the
case of having drawn this a biased coin
the probability of coming up with it
with it with the tail let's say a head
just to make my numbers a leisure
probability of coming out there with a
head is equal to 0.8 given that it's up
here in this choice the probability
given that you have a fair coin is 0.5
so now if we take the steeps the next
coin and take it to be a tail then the
probability of this guy given that
evidence is 0.2 and the probability of
this guy given that evidence it's a fair
coin so it doesn't care still 0.5 so now
what's the probability of this class
given this evidence it's the product of
0.5 times 0.8 times 0.2
and what's the probability of this guy
it's point five times 0.5 times 0.5
divided by a denominator which is the
same in both cases so let's forget about
this early point 5 here because it's the
same in both cases
and we just multiply those numbers
together that gives us 0.8 times 0.2
what's that once 0.16 and this guy 0.5
times 0.5 that's 0.25 so it looks awful
lot like with this combination that I've
picked the coin is that's fair one more
flip so let's flip it again and suppose
we come up with a head that puts a 0.8
in here and a 0.5 in here and when you
multiply those out
that's 0.125 and this is zero point one
two eight so it's about equal so you see
how that works all right so we're using
the coin flips as evidence to figure out
which class is involved okay so why
don't know you you probably like to see
a demonstration this too right
let you say to me gosh just two kinds of
coins that's not very interesting let's
try five kinds of points so what I'm
going to show you is a bunch of is how
the probabilities for all these coins
are five of them color-coded how they
how the probabilities vary with a series
of flips let's suppose I've got a head
the gray line by the way is the number
of heads or the fraction of heads so
that's going to be one because I'm just
doing hits hope you see that black line
not rising
shooting up like a rocket that's the
probability that the that's the pro
that's the that's the coin which it only
shows heads probability of head is one
and I'm flipping a whole bunch of heads
here not cool
now what happens if I suddenly put in a
tail by the way you'll note down here on
the extreme left the probability of the
the initial probability of the P equals
zero coin was 0.1 as soon as I flipped a
head that went to zero and will never
get off zero right that makes sense
because of the probability that a head
is one you should never see a tail if
you ever do that isn't your coin what
happens now if I interrupt a series of
heads and produce a tail what's that the
black one will go to zero what else
happens the blue one is the one with the
highest probability of being a head well
look boom that blue one shot up not
going up slowly it's shot up and is now
the preponderance of evidence with all
those heads is that I've flipped the
coin with a bias of 0.75 towards heads
so let's clear this pick any probability
you want point two five five and so on I
don't know let's pick point two five
since we've been at the upper end so
orange is 0.25 and sure enough the
probability that I've selected the 0.5
coin is going up and up and up and up
after a little original irregularity the
law of large numbers is setting in and a
probability I've got that 0.25 coin in
play is pretty close to 1 all right so
that's cool now you say to me uh that's
awfully nice but stop awfully nice but
not very not very real-world ish so let
me give you another problem it's well
known that you are with high probability
belong of the same political persuasion
as your parents so if I wanted to figure
out which party a parent belongs to I
could look at the party
that their children belong to right so
it's just like flipping points the
particular coin I I have chosen
corresponds to the parent the individual
flips correspond to the political party
that the child belongs to so let's get
up a little bit by the way I wrote all
this stuff over the weekend so who knows
a video a little work but let's see
party parent party classifier there it
is Democrats and Republicans and now the
prior for being a Republican I've given
here is 0.5 I but I don't know this is a
little bit Democratic state so let's
adjust that down a little bit that might
you know somewhere near might be about
right but that's just the sake of a
classroom illustration go down here so
now the meters showing the prior
probability because that's the only
thing in the formula so far I've got no
evidence
so now let's suppose that child number
one is a Republican back to neutral so
I've got a low probability that the
parent operatory probability of the
parent is a Republican and a child who's
a Republican I notice that point two and
point eight the product the conditional
is point eight and the priors point two
that's why it comes out to balance each
other right so now if we did another
Republican in there it goes way up if I
have a democratic child it goes back
down if I have an equal balance between
children then it goes way back down
because of that prior probability being
low so if I make that high and even
though the children are balanced I'm
still going to be have a high
probability of being a Republican now
let's see if I take that slider there
the conditional probability and drive it
to the left here let me make that
equally give and let's make that one
thing here I don't know what am i doing
now if I make the probability less than
point five what does that mean that
means you're sore at your parents and
you want to belong to a different party
okay all right so now what's next
oh gosh what's next this is what's next
what's next to somewhere yeah this is
what's next this here we got two models
remember I wanted I said we wanted to
decide between them can we use that
Bayesian hack to do that - sure because
we can we got these two models we've got
the probabilities in them so now I can
take my data and calculate the
probability of the left model given the
data and the probability of the right
model given the data multiply that times
their operative probabilities which are
all soo more equal then I can do a model
selection deal much in defiance of what
I was hinting at before so let's try
that whoa there are my two models yes
there they are
we've already trained them up with and
they've got their probabilities now what
we're going to do is we're going to use
the original model to do the same to
simulate the data so what we're going to
do is we're going to simulate draws
simulate events simulate combinations of
all the variables using a model that
looks like the one on the left that is
the one on the left except for the
slight difference of some probabilities
okay then we're going to do this
Bayesian thing and see where they meter
goes so run one data point oops went the
wrong way makes me nervous I just
finished this at 9:15
maybe there's a bug oops two data points
swings to the left it's three swings
back to the right of course that's not
much data so let's put some more data in
yeah oh there it goes let's try that
again that was cool so let's run
thousand simulations and one data point
wobbles around a little bit and goes
flat over to the left because that is
the model that reflects the one that the
data is generated from so now we got
Bayesian classification except now the
classification has gone one step more
and it becomes structure discovery we've
got two choices of structure and we can
use this Bayesian thing to decide which
of the
structures is best not cool well it's
only cool if you could do what so if you
had two choices you can select between
them and pick the best one but there
gosh for this number of variables there
are a whole lot of different networks
that satisfy the know looping criteria
and don't have very many parents it's an
awful lot of in fact if you restrict
this network to two parents they're
probably thousands and thousands of
possible structures so do I try them all
probably not has too much work when you
get 30 variables or something like that
so what do you do we know what to do
right we're almost veterans at 6:03 4 we
have to search so what we do is we take
the loser and we modify it and then we
modify it again we keep modifying it
until we drop dead or we get something
that we're happy with so let's see what
happens if we change this problem a
little bit and do structure discovery
we're starting out with nothing linked
and we're going to start running this
guy so what's going to happen is that
the good guy will prevail and the bad
guy will be a copy of the good guy
perturbed in some way so it's a random
search those that score that's too small
for you to read at all these things are
too small or let me make it a little
bigger too small to read but that number
on the right there is not the product of
the probabilities actually it's the sum
of the logarithms of the probabilities
they go together right and the reason
you use this instead of the
probabilities is because these numbers
get so small that with a 32-bit machine
you eventually lose so you use the log
of the probabilities rather than the
product of the probability uses some of
the logs instead of the product of the
these and eventually you hope that this
thing converges on on the correct
interpretation but you know what this
thing is so flat as a space and so large
and so telephone pole like that you have
to that it's full local Maxima so what
this program is doing is every once in a
while I think with probability 1 in 10 I
forgot what parameters I use every once
in a while it'll do a total radical
rearrangement of the structures in other
words it's a random restart it keeps
track of the best guy so far and every
once in a while there's a totally random
restart and it's effort to search this
space so that's how you go from probably
state inference to structure discovery
now when is this stuff actually useful
well I hinted at medical diagnosis right
that's a situation where you've got some
symptoms and you want to know what the
disease is so as soon as you use the
keyword diagnosis you've got a problem
for which this stuff is a candidate so
what other kinds of diagnosis problems
are there well you might be lying to me
so I can put a lie detector on you and
each of those variables that are
measured by the lie detector are
independent indication of whether you're
telling the truth or not so is this kind
of Bayesian is this kind of Bayesian
discovery thing
Bayesian naive Bayesian classification
what other kinds of problems speak to
the issue of diagnosis well we'd like to
know how well you know the material so
we can use quizzes as pieces of evidence
think that we don't use exactly a naive
Bayesian classifier because then we
wouldn't be able to do that combination
we have to use a slightly more complex
well you could think I was a slightly
more complex Bayesian net to do that
particular kind of diagnosis you might
have a spacecraft with all kinds or an
airplane or other piece of equipment
with all sorts of symptoms you're trying
to figure out what to do next what the
cause is so using the evidence to go
backward to the cause so maybe you got
some program that doesn't work
happens to me a lot so I use the
evidence from the symptoms of the
misbehavior and figure out where what's
the most probable cause is but now to
conclude the day last time last time
there were no there weren't any powerful
ideas but if you consider if you take
the combination of this the last lecture
in this lecture to be a candidate for
goal star ideas these are the ones I'd
like to leave you with we've got here is
this Bayesian stuff all these
probabilistic calculations are the right
thing to do is the right way to work
when you don't know anything which would
make it sound like you're not very
useful as you think you're always but
you in fact there are a lot of
situations where you either can't know
everything don't have time to know
everything or don't want to take the
effort to know everything so in medical
diagnosis all you got is these symptoms
you can't go in there and figure out in
a more precise way exactly what's wrong
so you use the symptoms to determine
what the causes and in all those other
kinds of cases that I mentioned but now
what other kinds of structure discovery
are there well the kind of structure
discovered that I hinted out of the
beginning will be the subject that we'll
begin with during our next
and sadly final conversation here in ten
250 on Wednesday it will feature not
only a discussion of how this stuff can
be used to discover patterns and stories
but we'll also talk about what's on the
final what kind of thing you could do
next that sort of thing to finish off
the subject and that's end of the story
for today
you